i'm delighted to welcome joanna mezel
who is going to tell us about uh
molecular errors criticism cryptic
sequences and the vulnerability
okay so i'm a biologist and there'll be
a little bit more of that in in this
evolvability talk but i'm going to keep
the biology simple
this is biology that probably everyone's
familiar with uh you have dna that makes
rna that makes a protein which has to
fold there are all these processes
transcription splicing translation
protein folding all involved in biology
so this function of genotype to
phenotype involves all these processes
and my talk is going to be all about
adding just one thing to this picture
and that thing is errors
so no molecular process is perfect
mostly they are extremely imperfect and
have substantial rates of errors in
transcription in splicing in translation
and in folding most of the time it you
know a huge proportion like you know a
large proportion of the total protein
products in the cell has had something
go wrong with it at some stage
so as an outline of this talk i'll start
by saying all right errors can happen
but how often and i'll show you a model
for the evolution of error rate assuming
that errors are under selection for
speed versus accuracy
and then
i'll look at um one of the the
consequences of this particularly when
is is to have high error rates and when
you have high error rates we get this
phenomenon of pre-screening normally we
think there's mutation and then
selection i'll show you selection before
mutation
which is very potent in terms of
evolvability
uh thirdly i'll show you what may be the
weirdest part of the story which we
normally biologists think that genetic
diversity is important for evolvability
and for this particular system it's not
and finally i'll apply this to
an example which is of the origin of
novelty which is taking new protein
sequences out of junk dna and sort of
getting something de novo
all right so let's uh start though with
this um speed versus accuracy
how much do errors happen yes before you
go on uh could you just define
evolvability because people are using it
here oh sure um so i'm a biologist and
i'm looking in terms of
the organism's ability on our sort of
the population's ability on average to
respond to a new environmental challenge
and come up with something different
specifically i'm looking at the origin
of novelty a population's ability to
come up with potentially adaptive
novelties
is that
um
so some like um
massimo pelucci's given like this scheme
of three time scales sort of the
quantitative genetics time scale the
huge kind of origin of life macro
evolution time scale and an intermediate
time scale um all of this work is at the
intermediate time scale uh not just the
change in yellow frequencies that
already exist but involving novelty but
not necessarily involving clade level or
huge um history of life type questions
so that intermediate time scan yeah you
said that the large portion of protein
production in the cell is actually on
its projects yeah probably twenty thirty
separated by brighton exclusive yes what
is the percentage uh so we don't think
we have an exact number but various of
the errors have been quantified
individually um the highest error rates
seem to be in translation and based on
sort of various extrapolation and back
of the envelope calculations people are
coming up with something like 20 to 30
percent for the proteins subject to some
kind of error
some of them will function anyway of
course has it been demonstrated
confirmed by master product with us
no that because there's it's it's a sum
over many many many errors that you
don't have the sensitivity experimental
sensitivity to detect that plus a lot of
them are folding errors
you know so the master can't get that
all right so there's one really
important observation
behind the work i'm going to show you
and that's that when you make an error
any kind of error in biology there's an
intrinsic bimodality to its consequences
but either you break something or you
tinker with it
um you can delete a gene or change its
promoter region a little so it's
expressed slightly differently you can
change the protein sequence so that it's
no longer thermostable and instead forms
toxic amyloid or you can do something
that just is in a flexible part and
actually has no effect at all on either
function or fault
and this bimodality of having something
really bad or benign
is fairly common across biology and we
can derive it from first principles with
respect to a huge variety of molecular
examples
we can also see it at the whole organism
level when we infer
the distribution of fitness effects of
new mutations and you see it's very
bimodal there are lethal mutations there
are relatively neutral mutations and
there's a huge gap in the middle it's
extremely bimodal
so for the purposes of this talk i'm
going to talk about one particular kind
of error um partly because we study that
a lot in my lab and partly because um
it's just to keep things concrete
and that's reading through a stop codon
so the most common effect of reading
through a stop codon and reading into
the untranslated region of the of the
rna is that three out of 64 of the
codons are stopped so there's usually a
second stop codon in there somewhere so
it will read through the second stop
codon you get additional amino acids and
then they will either cause a complete
misfolding of the protein or they'll
have a relatively benign effect as a
floppy tail
many of the things i'm going to tell you
are general other kinds of errors too
so we'll say that this error happens at
rate rho
of reading through under normal
circumstances you can do the rho squared
term too which we did but it doesn't
really matter
um so
basically whether it's benign
or
highly misfolded deleterious depends on
what's going on in the sequence so this
is a cryptic sequence beyond the stop
codon
and mutation bias
tends to favor the deleterious forms it
is a minority of forms accessible to
mutation that are benign but it's not an
overwhelming massive
um
majority but there's a clear bias
towards this so if rho is really small
and this cryptic sequence is evolving
neutrally then the probability of being
in one state versus another will be
given by this overall mutational
equilibrium
if rho is larger
then there can be selection not just on
the primary product but also on the
cryptic product the conditional product
that is expressed just a little bit
because of the errors that takes place
in translation and then in that case
there will be natural selection against
this form which will shift this
mutational equilibrium and make it a
mutation selection equilibrium instead
so this takes place in a population um
this is all an asexual model we're
working on the sexual version right now
but this asexual model is very easy each
individual can be summarized by just uh
two numbers
uh the um
and
one is the the the um
error rate and the other is how many of
sorry sorry it's not a population this
is an individual my bad um here's an
individual it has lots of genes each of
them reads through the stop codon all at
right row
and of these ldl of them
i have deleterious effects out of the l
total the rest of them are benign
the next one sorry is the population
each individual is described by two
numbers
how many of their loci are sensitive to
this particular error
and what is the error rate
those two numbers describe each
individual in the population
so um
so we have a model now which has costs
and benefits of doing proofreading the
easiest way to get the error rate down
is to add proofreading machinery that
finds the errors and prevents them from
really happening
um
so
the cost has costs and benefits the
benefits are obvious fewer deleterious
protein crud is produced we have two
different models for that cost of
protein crowd a multiplicative model
that roughly corresponds to loss of
function and an additive model that
roughly corresponds to gain of toxic
function
they're very very different functional
forms but the results are almost
superimposable
these slides happen to have the
multiplicative model on them
so
basically the higher the error rate the
more crud is produced fitness is flat
for a long while and then declines
catastrophically
so
on the other hand proofreading doesn't
come for free presumably there's some
opportunity cost that resources that the
cell puts into proofreading could be
used for something else
so we assume
diminishing returns arise very naturally
that a given unit of opportunity cost in
time or energy corresponds to a
geometric decrease in the number of
errors made so you know to remove half
the errors you have to add a certain
unit of
commitment and delta here is a very
small parameter that corresponds to
essentially to what percentage of all
the things the the cell has to do what
percentage of those involve stopping at
stop codons
so and then you get this cost benefit
your fitness is on a log scale here and
you put the two together
and there is an optimum
error rate
in that system
so this optimum is if you have a certain
number of deleterious sequences then
evolution will happen on the
proofreading such that a certain error
rate evolves
but actually it's a co-evolutionary
process because whether the sequences
are deleterious or benign can also
evolve
and so
when you have very very low error rates
this evolution here is this neutral
mutational equilibrium and so this this
represents that there and then as the
error rate gets higher and higher
selection starts to drive the number of
deleterious sequences down
and in a small population this is a
selection effective population size
indicating the
ability of natural selection to take
effect on things of
small selection coefficients
in that case you evolved to this single
attractor on this graph
when
in populations where selection is more
effective
um then you see this this decrease are
for
smaller rates of error than you did
before
and now you get uh one unstable and two
stable attractors arising in this system
so what are these two sub attractors
correspond to and
they really are very different so there
are two ways of dealing with the issue
of molecular errors
one
is to uh
let them happen to let these deleterious
sequence happen but to do lots and lots
of proofreading so what's beyond the
stop codon stays behind the stop codon
it never matters because it all gets
proof read and never gets expressed and
that's this attractor over here that has
a low error rate the alternative is to
have a higher erect
let the errors happen and instead
purge the deleterious sequences and have
selection on each one so that each
cryptic sequence evolves to have benign
effects
so
we see this by stability and you can see
that this is naturally by bistable in
the sense that if you have one if you
say you have a really good proof reading
you're going to evolve deleterious
sequences which means you need more
proofreading same thing if you have a
very few deleterious sequences then you
don't need proofreading anymore which
means you can you know you get rid of it
and you have even fewer so you can see
the positive feedback loop that
naturally gives rise to this
evolutionary by stability
uh so
we see this by stability for quite a big
range of selection effective population
sizes
um
so basically um if you have very small
populations they do proofreading if you
have extremely large ones then they do
the uh
purging instead and have high error
rates and in between around the range in
fact where routinely biological
populations are believed to be you have
by stability
and the other factor that really matters
here is uh the number of loci that that
proofreading mechanism works on so
something that just proofreads one of
the three stop codons
refers to fewer loci than something that
acts on all three stop codons and as you
can imagine um when you have a
proofreading mechanism that acts on more
things that does favor proofreading
over a larger range but more
dramatically than that you can see this
this line is kind of plateauing out it
doesn't get really pushed that far more
dramatically than that you further
increase the range and under which
things are by stable you mainly get rid
of this attractor rather than
get rid of this one
so
uh
just in case you don't care about stop
codon read through as much as i do um
i'll phrase this in more general terms
again so basically this model applies
whenever you have an error
a global so the error here is written
through a stop codon a global solution
the proofreading where you deal with
that error at every locus at the same
time in this case by ribosomes release
factors and a local solution um in this
case having a benign cryptic sequence in
three prime utr
obviously splicing errors are extremely
similar you can have a better splice
build a blade of spliceosome or you can
have a benign not necessarily functional
but benign alternative minor splice form
uh the most famous global solution is
perhaps chaperones which mainly account
for folding errors the alternative is to
solve something kinetically and have
something that has a sequence that's
really good at folding by itself
and chaperones clean up pretty much any
mess whatsoever it seems so you can have
folding errors that are due to uh errors
during translation and a local solution
for that would be to use better codon
usage so that you get less of this going
on
yes so when stop cardone reads through
happens what amino acid is used like
when for regulation selena system is
used but when it is an error what amino
acid is substituted whatever's in the
untranslated
part of the rna past the stop codon
which is what i'm calling the crippling
is not coded at all
in this there is three nucleotides
corresponding to stop carbons that's
right what amino acid oh which oh it's
usually a
trna
um so it's something that it's one of
the rnas that binds something that's one
base one nucleotide off from what the
stop codon is
okay so evolvability which is what i'm
supposed to be talking about
yes before you go to the next point with
regard to this since i care about stop
quadrupling almost as much as you oh
um so
do you manage to detect
any
kind of protein level selection in the
read through regions we are still
working on it i wish i had we
i have one result we got like two days
before i came on friday but i'm not
ready to talk about it yet
um all right
but um
but the main results i want i'm still
waiting on we we've been trying for
years it's a harder problem than i
initially thought global approached
optimizing
yeah no we really we really want to do
this i'm not ready to talk about it yet
it's very high priority for me
okay so evolvability
um
so
that which attractor evolves really
makes a difference
so to look at this we set up now a
quantitative trait model where the
regular sequence contributes to a trait
value and so does the cryptic sequence
and the cryptic sequence only
contributes with strength proportional
to rho because it's not expressed very
much
but if you are to get a point mutation
in a stop codon i call this co-option
it's also you can see it as a form of
genetic assimilation if you're familiar
with that term
um then something that used to be
cryptic
now becomes fully expressed you don't
multiply it by row anymore and if
you had a high error rate before
then these mutations
will
create variants that will not misfold
all right so they won't at least they
may not be adaptive but at least they
won't be unbelievably toxic
uh
so what we do is we have this trait
value and we have a gaussian function of
fitness as a function of the trait and
then at some point in evolution we
change what the optimal trait value is
and what we see
is with two populations that are really
identical in very profound ways because
the only difference was the starting
conditions so that they evolved to one
rather than the other attractor
you get a dramatic increase in the speed
of evolution in the evolvability when
you have the high error rate attractor
which is able to tap in these this
pre-screened
pool of cryptic variants it has access
to a whole lot of co-option mutations
that this attractor does not have access
to
so a way of drawing this here's our by
mode about dality this is lethal this
can only be better
and the idea is we don't know in
evolution what's going to be adaptive in
the future and this is often said that
we can't study evolvability because
i think you know evolution is myopic it
doesn't know what's going to be coming
however we do know what's not going to
be adaptive
it is never going to be adaptive to be
sterile or dead it is never going to be
adaptive to you know ditch this basic
essential function to not you know
so
if you get rid of those gu all of this
stuff that will be adaptive in the
future is probably among these
deleterious mutations not among these
deleterious questions yes is it really
true
no no i'm not i'm just saying you know
okay fine they can be it could be useful
to be sterile and dead in a very
regulated fashion where your relatives
are not sterile and dead um but if it's
just you're sterile and do because of a
basic housekeeping gene mutation that's
that's all i'm referring to i don't
think it can still be
she'll be good because if your
population being smaller and not messing
up the environment in the future i mean
it's not if you look at the longer term
fitness that's also that's also a kid
selection argument ultimately
um i don't mean to diskin selection here
that's not what i'm where i was going
i'm just talking about you know yeah
let's leave that another conversation
all right so what i am saying is when
you have this high error rate going on
what you get is selection that's
extremely effective on this mode and
basically almost neutral on this mode
and this is a consequence of there being
a critical value
of s
higher than which selection is very
effective lower than which selection
virtually doesn't exist which has been a
fairly robust result in population
genetics
this is the higher attractor and in the
higher retractor that critical value of
s
falls between these two modes
while um the the sequences are in the
cryptic state
and that allows selection to eliminate
these guys while not doing anything to
these guys
and that's a consequence of the
non-linearity of the probability of a
fixation of a
of an allele with respect to its
selection coefficient
and so i call this pre-adapting
selection
because
yeah because selection is happening in a
way to make the adaptation easier in the
future
so the bottom line for this why it works
is that molecular errors in the present
like reading through a stop codon
resemble mutations in the future like
mutating that stop codon
the dna replication
looks a lot like transcription and
translation in some essential
mechanistic
characteristics
and it's that correspondence between
molecular and developmental errors
and the mutational landscape that gives
rise to this phenomena by which the the
worst of the sequences are purged in
favor of benign ones before they even
appear by mutation
and then you have this pool of benign
sequences that are available
for mutational co-option
so that goes for anything with high
errors just a couple of examples out
there promiscuous enzyme activities that
can catalyze one reaction and then
incidentally can do another
um you know then co-op they can be gene
duplicated and then co-opted to
specialize in the the second activity
that was an accident
um protein protein interactions you can
have a regular one that's functional and
some other one
that uh is not functional but it happens
but maybe the two proteins involved just
don't see each other very often and then
a mutation happens and that co-opts this
protein protein interaction because now
they see each other all the time
and there's a bit of an aside because um
just to show how important these
molecular errors are
we did another study on protein protein
interactions
and we did this thing where we took the
worst possible
protein protein interaction data we
could from used to hybrid with no
quality strains on it and we compared
that to the absolute best data we can
which was affinity capture mass spec
with all these quality controls
and we got the bad data predicting
meaningful properties better than the
good data did
and so the bottom line of what that
means is that stickiness the propensity
to to to interact in error was more
important than hubness
in
evolution during evolution and in the
constraints on these proteins in other
words
are you claiming that stickiness is an
adaptive tape there no i'm just saying
stickiness is what it is some proteins
perhaps functional constraint reasons
are very sticky if a protein is just
non-specifically sticky which this will
assay very well
then that has a large effect on noise
and plasticity
but how much of a hub it is has no
effect on noise and plasticity
okay but let let's get this thing
do you believe there is selection
against stickiness at all yes i suspect
except except maybe for like activated
transcription factors where stickiness
might be intrinsic to their function
which is to recruit
but in general for a protein that's
doing something specific rather than
recruiting function yes i think there's
selection against non-specific
stickiness
but there is nevertheless a huge
proteins are non-specifically sticky you
know by default
so you know it's only so far that it
gets driven down and these high error
rates if you think of errors protein
protein interaction the error rates are
really high
what is hardness like how many things
how many other proteins a protein has a
meaningful functional protein
interaction with degree but functional
degree and i'm saying non-functional
degree
is more predictive of the data than
functional degree
bad data predicts
things better than good data does
that was a fun result i thought
oh the things were
how noisy different jeans are and how
plastic they are how much their
expression level goes up and down in
different environmental conditions
uh then those were realistic-ish
environmental conditions all of this in
sacraments
okay so another weird bit um
uh genetic polymorphism not required for
evolvability
um
so to just to say that you know when i
say genetic diversity is not required so
what i want to do is i want to look at
this model of genetic sequences with and
without
genetic diversity and the starting point
that we had here i'm sure many of you
are familiar with andreas wagner's ideas
that there's this big genotype space or
neutral network and the spread
of across this this neutral network
allows the population to evolve to more
different places and so the genetic
diversity or spread across this network
is believed to be the key to the
evolvability
um so we wanted to look at that
situation in our system with and without
the ability to have genetic diversity
so right now we're assuming we're in the
higher evolvability attractor with
benign sequences and a high error rate
and we're just looking at the effect
sizes of these these cryptic sequences
and so here's a cell
and it matches its environment more or
less it has a sequence that's a darker
shade of blue plus two but that has very
little effect on its phenotype because
it's attenuated because it's cryptic
and the normal view of how things work
is because of the crypticity you get
relaxed selection because of the relaxed
selection you get cryptic genetic
variation so some individuals have minus
two some of them have plus two if it
gets too extreme then maybe natural
selection starts to weed it out but you
get this range and that's the genetic
diversity that's believed to contribute
to evolvability
and it does that because if the
environment changes it might change in
different directions but hopefully
there'll be some allele out there that
can easily co-opt the cryptic sequence
and evolve in that particular direction
so putting this in wagner's view of a
neutral network or genotype space here
you have three genotypes
centered inside this neutral network
they're neutral because basically to all
intents and purposes these guys have the
same phenotype the same fitness
but because there are three of them each
of them can mutate to get to a different
place and so a population spread out
across these three
is more evolvable
so in our system though this is this is
all well and good when you're talking
about like the most common thing this
has been done with is how an rna forms a
stem loop structure
maybe eventually people will manage to
apply it well to protein folding rather
than just rna folding but whatever it is
these are phenotypes where there's only
one gene
and as we all know most biological
phenotypes
involve multiple genes
so when you have multiple genes
you can get lots of options even with no
genetic diversity whatsoever
so here we have two genetically
identical individuals but it can still
go to either minus one or plus one or
minus two
by co-opting at different genes rather
than co-opting in different individuals
so drawing this out we now have a
neutral network of precisely one
genotype but instead it can get to three
different places just by itself and the
reason it can do that is because there
are three loci involved
so the question is what's more important
for the evolvability
um
this is we're called sort of spread and
this is sometimes called neighborhood
richness so here's another picture we
did in it this is the andreas wagner
view where you have a region of genotype
and all of the different individuals are
spread across it and they can reach many
different phenotypes because there are
many different starting point genotypes
from which they can mutate
and here's the other view so this is the
diverse population the other view which
you're calling the neighborhood richness
view
rather than polymorphism view that uh
one individual just is living in a
genotype with one population so one
genotype all individuals in the
population are living in an area where
there are a really rich mutational
neighborhood from which they can reach
many many different phenotypes
and of course this could all happen at
the same time in principle you know that
genotype space is big
um so the question is where does
evolution induct does evolution end up
in this kind of place or this kind of
place and so on
anyway so to model this
we are
looked at um having cryptic sequences
and we had multiple traits here and so
now this cryptic effect effect has a
vector where it affects each of the
trait dimensions
and when it's cryptic we multiply these
effects by row
and when a co-option mutation occurs you
no longer multiply that one by row and
you get a movement in trait space
um
and so by co-opting across different
loci
you can end up exploring trade space
and if you have multiple starting
genotypes
if the polymorphism view is true you
should be able to substantially increase
the exploration of trait space
so to quantify whether the na the which
whether the polymorphism view is correct
or not
we took the average distance in
multi-dimensional trade space between
individuals that were co-opted from the
same starting genotype
and we compared that to the total
pairwise distance across individuals
that did not necessarily start from the
same
initial genotype
and that ratio gives us a metric of how
much of the phenotypic potential of the
system
is due to neighborhood richness you know
that this is how much of it you would
have had even if there were no genetic
diversity at all
and one minus that can obviously
quantify
how important genetic diversity is
so when there's only one locus
there is no neighborhood richness there
is only ever one place to go
so
all um
all of this this this black line
is is completely explained by um genetic
diversity
and what we see is that as things get
more and more cryptic
you get an increase in the total amount
of variation that can be accessed
when we allow for multiple loci there's
this radical idea that most most traits
depend on multiple genes
firstly we get dramatically more um
phenotypic diversity in general even
accounting for differences in mutational
target size
uh secondly that increase happens sort
of an order of magnitude or so lower
values of or higher values of whatever
less crypticity
and um
and finally whenever genetic diversity
is highest
then that genetic diversity is basically
entirely accounted for by neighborhood
richness and genetic polymorphism
doesn't contribute anything
and this yellow dot and that triangle
correspond by the way to the high
vulvability attractor in the first part
of the talk
so
we had to scratch our heads for quite a
while to figure out what's going on here
but we figured it out eventually and
what's really important to understanding
the story is compensatory evolution
that when a mutation happens of a large
effect size
sometimes you'll be eliminated by
natural selection
almost never will you get a back
mutation
but not infrequently you get a
compensatory mutation
and because of these compensatory
mutations you end up with large effect
sizes accumulating in the cryptic
sequences and they also ex because they
have opposite directions they also
explore the range of phenotypic
possibilities pretty efficiently
and that's why there's so little to be
gained by
genetic polymorphism
so the bottom line there is that the
spread across the genotype space is not
required that this is a better
understanding of the higher vulvability
of polygenic traits in asexuals we
already knew that none of this applies
to sexual so far all of the
involvability this morning including me
has all been about asexuals obviously in
sexuals recombination is kind of
important but we're not really talking
about that right now
all right but you know this was believed
to be an asexual model and now this one
and i'm saying not just is it restricted
to asexuals it's restricted to single
gene traits
in asexuals
okay so for evolvability in my model
what you need
firstly you need a minimum level of
selection on cryptic sequences to purge
the misfolded options that's what i
showed you in the second part of the
talk in the third part of the talk i
said basically you want selection as
weak as possible above that minimum
because the weaker selection is the more
compensatory evolution you're going to
get the higher the diversity of the
cryptic sequences
so you may say well i'm making a knife
edge argument i'm saying that the
selection has to be high enough for this
but low for that and you know that that
probably isn't going to happen
and
the reason this isn't a problem
is the first part of the talk
this knife edge is also known as the
high vulvability attractor
the knife edge is an attractor so what
you get in the attractor is you get the
absolute
lowest level of selection that will
purge the miss folders and nothing any
stronger than that that is exactly what
evolves in the high ability of all so
basically the nature of the speed and
accuracy trade-off fortuitously gives
you
the best possible error rate for
evolvability
all right if i have time do i have time
to briefly mention the applications
of the work um
so uh the application that we've been
looking at is uh how you get protein
coding sequences from non-coding
sequences in particular this idea that
they are pre-screened in advanced is
this purging happening
um so the first work we did on this was
on stop codon read through and um this
was a while back and we looked in
just to look for events in which a stop
codon had been lost and you actually saw
this cryptic sequence becoming coding
and this could be confirmed because you
could still see
that uh this this sequence here was
aligned very well and was homologous
with a very low pulse positive rate to
these sequences there
and we found a bunch of this happening
so we found direct evidence and this is
kind of a puzzle biochemists
expect random protein sequences to be
highly deleterious
a generic
form of polypeptide is amyloid it
aggregates it's nasty people didn't
expect the general view of genes is is
new genes come from old genes through
duplication it was thought to be
impossible
that new genes just come
out of nothing out of non-coding out of
random sequences but it turns out that
they do
um and this is a growing field but
there's more and more and more and more
evidence that complete genes are also
evolving de novo and not just pieces of
genes
so basically the model that i've given
you can describe why that can happen so
basically transcription happens anyway
because errors happen it's all about the
errors
usually the transcripts just degraded
but maybe sometimes that degradation
fails because biology is all about
errors and so the transcript gets away
if it gets away it'll probably make it
into the cytoplasm where it could
associate with ribosomes and if there is
a start codon and a stop codon
that may be all it needs in order to get
translated
it doesn't have a really optimized
sequence for translation so the
translation is likely to be extremely
low levels but hey in error some random
thing
got out there if it's highly deleterious
there'll be selection against it or in
favor of a more benign version of this
and that benign version is available for
co-option
and when
stuff in this category
pre-screened stuff gets co-opted you can
get a new de novo
gene from junk dna
so
here the co-op div is the mutation which
will make it not happen by accident not
just that's right so it could be
anything so for example it could be a
transport signal it could be a
translation initially it could be
something in the secondary structure
that makes translation initiate or
finish more easily there could be
something that
makes that vastly increases so instead
of low levels it suddenly gets expressed
at more appreciable ones
and there's a lot of ways that could
happen
and in your yeast example do you know
that you haven't added a stop codon as
opposed to your
product well of course you there's
always a stop codon so back to the yeast
yeah so here you know you lose this top
coat on and then this there's a new one
i mean
because three out of 64 of them are
stopped so there's one there
and right now we're doing polymorphisms
on this there's heaps of polymorphisms
in yeast on this
yeah so what we're getting is errors at
each stage and there are multiple stage
here give a preview of the next stage so
this pre-adapting selection can happen
at each of these stages
and uh what we did and by we i mean ben
who's sitting in the back there um is uh
tested whether stage three
is is common or not um because that's a
critical part of the theory for my
theory to explain
de novo gene evolution there's got to be
a lot of stuff
living in three so that's what we wanted
to test that the
length of the open breeding frame in the
cryptic region might be longer if there
was more adaptation
of that section uh shorter i would
predict it'd be shorter and it is
shorter actually that's one of the
if it was
if there was more selection
no probably probably because it's not
selection to adapt adaptive it's just
selection to be benign and a shorter one
is more likely to be benign than a
longer one and they are a little shorter
than you'd expect
in yeah they are a little shorter than
you expect
um
okay so what ben did
is he took the ribosomal profiling data
from jonathan weissman's lab basically
there are ribosomes sitting on the rna
and everything gets digested out except
that and then you look and sequence what
rna is hidden under the ribosome and
i've heard this described as a pseudo
proteome
it's using nucleic acid technology to
get a snapshot of translation so it's
kind of in my view better than proteome
data
so
the question is are non-coding
transcripts associated with ribosome do
we have the raw materials from which
this co-option could occur
and so he used uh footprints that
exactly mapped only so sort of high
stringency stuff and found that um over
half of the non-coding transcripts
showed high levels of ribosomal
association
and
here's the histograms of it so protein
coding in grey have some level of
density of ribosomes
the non-coding or supposedly non-coding
sequences obviously have fewer ribosomes
on them but there is substantial overlap
lots of them have
gene-like these are non-coding of
various kinds just anything that's
anything that's been annotated as a
non-coding transcript in sacraments
yes so we looked at that and then sorry
especially since he's here ben looked at
that and he checked every single one of
them to see whether any of them might
actually be a coding gene in disguise
and one of them was it happened to be an
outlier out here and so this this is the
real fun thing where two theoreticians
get to find a new gene in sacramento's
you know highlight of my career um
so this is you know the theoretician
discovered gene um and this is you can
see here's a 28 amino acid off the
ribosomal hits you know are concentrated
exactly where the auth is in the
transcript it's this guy's definitely
getting translated and there's no way of
annotating this any other way because
it's way too short for a hidden markov
model or whatever to count it as real
and you can't annotate it as according
to conservation in other yeast species
because it only just evolved
so and things that only just evolved the
de novo ones tend to be short
so there's massive ascertainment bias
meaning we're not seeing the de novo
genes and we're not seeing the short
orbs which happen often to be the same
things so the ribosomal profiling is a
good way of getting at it and here was
the gene
um
so that's it i called it a gene it's
definitely a coding sequence we have no
idea if it's functional or not but it's
a coding sequence all right there's a
protein that's getting made from that
actually i may be missing something but
what makes you think that the production
of this 28 amino acid peptide is not
just an error
it could be it's just um
what i'm saying it could be an error but
it's happening what we can say is the
descriptive thing
this 28 amino acid off is getting
translated into protein but if you put
the previous slide on it which gets
transacted a lot
yeah yeah so it turned out to have a
high density on the histogram
so in that respect
so so and what ben did is he looked at
all of them to see if any of them like
how well they correspond so a lot of
non-coding stuff a lot of the ribosomes
bind non specifically and they're
binding increases in starvation
conditions and there's a sort of a bunch
of things of what non-coding looks like
and most of them followed that most of
them bound more in starvation than in
rich media and so on this one had all
the patterns that one normally
associates with a coding sequence so so
so can you check the phone is this off
like ribosomal density
or does this offline cryobasement
density
positively correlated the lengths of
those orbs that are detectable in those
things yeah so most of this is not
highly or sorry of the black one is not
highly off associated
if the ribosome is getting out there
there is enrichment around the start
codon
there may be no oil
and there may be
limited off correlation along the length
of the triangle if i take you know the
bins that have orbs between 15 and 20
and 10 and 50.
oh will the pair of bean have more of
such observations than you do not
so
i should start to shall it be answered
um so basically what we found is what
was the over representation of the start
code on it was only like 50 extra right
that was what we did was was look at how
much extra there was at the start code
on because the start codon is bound to
be part of any off
and uh it was only like a 50 percent you
know higher over representation compared
to other positions so the signal is very
mild
yes uh so you said that uh ribosomal
profiling is better than proteomics and
it's a very controversial statement of
course because weissman himself now is
trying to validate all his ribosomal
graphite by protonic studies but in this
particular case it would be extremely
easy to confirm everything by just
trying simple mass spectrometry
experiment yeah so we've looked into it
um i don't want to do a proteomic type
mass spec experiment i spoke to some
mass effect people so because i don't
run a wet lab
um we think it's possible but if you
want to do it with a proper positive
control you know there's only so many
cleavage sites there's only
so many options with these short
proteins we think this one can be done
we haven't done it yet we should
um me not having a wet lab has been one
of the delays on that
but we we should get around to that our
proteomics person
you know leaving the university also
contributed to the delay
but yes i actually believe i do believe
in mass spec
but i i like targeted mass spec where
you know what you're looking for you
have a positive control
and you know and you know what what what
concentration you could have seen
the the genome y and you can reach for
it and all sorts of and you enrich the
fraction for it first i'm less enamored
i guess part of it came from my
experience from the de novo gene field
like there are a couple of papers on de
novo genes in primates and one of them
reported like 60 and one of them
reported four but there was no overlap
between the two sets and we delved into
it and they'd use different builds of
the proteomics
and so it's like my best and i got was
don't trust that spec i mean if they if
the builds don't correspond enough to
you know if it's affecting the bottom
line result that much then i'm not
confident in the product in the in the
the global proteomics might ask one more
question that is relevant to this so
reading through stop cardones
is also not only a matter but it's also
important regulatory mechanism in selena
proteins
and when it happens
you cannot hide it from modern
proteomics technology it's very easy to
detect reading through stroke codon
because there is a tryptic peptides
after the stockholder
so if you mean an e coli
anywhere
there's some cases of it now now it is
showing up really nicely in jonathan
weissman's data no no i'm talking about
i'm talking about reading through
stop cardone regulatory mechanism
this
if you have it it's impossible to hide
it from modern technologies because it's
very easy to detect by mass spectrometry
because there are tryptic peptides as
after stock carbons now if your error
related readings through stock cardones
indeed happens at any reasonable
rate
you wouldn't be able to escape
like heidi from modern proteomics
technology but no current reasons
proteogenomic studies show
that there are actually any evidence of
reading through stop cardone at any
significant rate
um so
right now we're real so jonathan's got
more data that's not released and i
haven't actually even got a copy of it
i've just heard rumors of it but i won't
talk to that i'll just talk to his old
data
in his data that shows stop codon read
through he didn't report on them but
we've gone over the data and we see them
in his data
um the error prone stuff that we're
looking at for to be the higher
volability attractor like 0.3 read
through is enough you're not going to
see that in mass spec
what you do see at least in
the profiling is you can see a few
percent read through or higher
um you can't see much more resolution
than that there are definitely genes out
there including in the released data set
that haven't been commented on yet that
show significantly higher read through
errors rates
now the question of what's programmed
and what's just a higher than usual
error rate is an open one just like with
this gene i'm happy to call it a protein
calling anything functional
is always problematic in evolutionary
biology this seems to me like a
conversation that can be best to
continue some protein
yeah okay i'm nearly done i would just
have like two slides
so anyway i just said de novo revolution
we've talked about that but what i
wanted to say is what we did prove is
that the penultimate stage of gene birth
is widespread showing that i think we
may relate to that data okay errors are
common and important
there are two ways of reacting to them
proofreading
for all sites at once or robustness to
each one individually
this high error rate has this
pre-screening and evolvability
in this case what's going on is
neighborhood richness not genetic
diversity
and you can see
support for this general
world view through the de novo gene case
the bigger picture i wanted to conclude
on
is is just a plea for the beauty of mess
that that waste mass errors they're not
just a nuisance they're the essence of
biology
all of the whole evolvability case that
i've just built is based on the
inevitability of mistakes um but looking
for exactly this is how the molecular
machine work
can miss the essence of biology the
essence of biology is why does evolution
work why are not all mutations
deleterious the answer in this work to
why all mutations are not deleterious is
because there was selection because of
errors even before the mutation occurred
um so really creative innovation
requires mess all right
i want to thank people including ben for
that last bit
who's now at the investigative young who
did most of the theory work and two
other former undergrads who did some of
the other bioinformatics i mentioned and
a plug that i'm hiring right now
and thank you